players with how to Berlin are busy
preparing for this weekend's game but
that's a purely routine matter the
discussion over Thomas hits those
beggars coming out certainly is not big
finstock does i think it's great he
outed himself and i think he won't be
the only one among current players now
hbu the other and already can be petite
respect for I have a real respect for
mr. hit salzburger I wouldn't have had
the courage this will probably be hugely
height hit so swagger may have
anticipated this when he revealed in an
interview that he's gay hitless beggar
the first German international to do so
said he spoke up to help other gay
athletes by talking about it the way I
do now it encourages some others because
they see they can still be professional
football players they can't let the
highest level and be gay it's not a
contradiction as I proved and therefore
hopefully it gives some encouragement to
young players his former teammate lukas
podolski hailed his move as an important
signal former english national player
gary lineker also tweeted
congratulations even British Prime
Minister David Cameron expressed his
admiration for hitzlsperger who played
in the English Premier League it's oz
burger said soccer remained the world of
matches but he hopes that will change I
know that my family and my closest
friends to them it's not important that
I talk about my experiences as a
homosexual football player but it's more
important for those people who
discriminate others because of their
sexuality and those people now now they
have a pronounced opponent it's las vega
is no longer battling for the ball on
the pitch instead he'll be fighting off
the field for more tolerance in soccer